you went to school for all of
so much different things yeah i'm sure a
lot of that you ended up applying to
what you're doing now for sure because a
lot of people are like well you know if
you want to be in the music industry you
really don't got to go to school but
like i feel like a lot of people who do
go to school it ends up helping them out
yeah because there's so much you can
apply to
any sort of situation i'm
psychology part first is just like
just understanding people and
understanding how to move in different
rooms and just understanding how to
switch faces being in different places
whether it's in the streets whether it's
in a boardroom whether it's in a
classroom
so that that really helped me out a lot
just being able to speak the language of
a lot of different people um
journalism perspective like just getting
like write-ups and [ __ ] done right on
one sheet and understanding how to put
that in format
and then [ __ ] the pr part it just speaks
of course of course like i just
understood that
marketing so and i was around the time
where
instagram started to actually develop an
algorithm when i was in college so it
wasn't really a algorithm yet but that
was what they were teaching us in class
so it was like i was just learning it so
fast early on not knowing that the music
[ __ ] was gonna be able to be applied to
it down